as Bendixon talked about on the bonus
show yesterday Ivanka Trump was recently
booed and laughed at and hissed at when
she was onstage at a women's rights
conference in Germany after she went on
and on about how much her father Donald
respects women and would do anything for
women here's her tweet or rather here's
a tweet that Donald Trump posted
yesterday about this saying quote proud
of Ivanka Trump for her leadership on
these important issues women's issues
looking forward to hearing her speak at
the w20 which is the women's summit now
according to documents that were just
leaked Donald Trump wants to take away
all funding from a State Department
office that focuses on promoting women's
rights around the world wants to go from
eight point two five million dollars in
funding to zero point zero what we're
talking about is the office of global
women's issues and what they do
throughout the world is promote women's
social development economic development
women's involvement in government they
work against gender-based violence and
many other women's issues
April happens to be sexual assault
awareness month in the United States and
how fitting that during that month a
president who was elected despite having
been accused of sexual harassment and
sexual assault by well more than a dozen
women I don't even know what the number
is and claimed that there is no bigger
friend to women than him is cutting
funding for women's foreign aid
according to the nonpartisan
international charitable organization
Oxfam quote this will have dire
consequences for millions of people as
well as our global standing national
security interests and the values
central to America's identity mu Simbi
can euro who's the president of the
Global Fund for women said to the
independent quote this program took a
leadership stance on women's rights
amplified the voices of grassroots
women's leaders and enacted important
policies like the u.s. Global Strategy
to empower adolescent girls
which carried the potential to ensure
more girls globally are educated healthy
and free from violence my biggest
problem with this other than the obvious
insanity of Donald Trump claiming to be
a friend to women and cutting funding
claiming that he respects women more
than anyone yet he's been accused by
more than a dozen women of sexually
harassing women is that we're talking
about almost no money when it comes to
what the government spends eight million
dollars is just nothing I mean it is
nothing think about what the Syrian
airstrikes cost us which accomplished
nothing think about what the mother of
all bombs cost eight million dollars I
mean it is it is just not even worth
Trump thinking about whether to defund
this Hillary Clinton championed the
State Department program as Secretary of
State and as a presidential candidate
this is not Donald Trump's first move as
president to regress the improvement of
women's lives around the world you'll
remember that in January
Trump cut off all federal funding to
non-governmental medical organizations
overseas that provide abortion services
which is yet another decision that
acutely and disproportionately hurts
women the same month the women's march
against Donald Trump was the largest
protest in American history and there's
one other note I think that's important
here that people should take note of if
you refuse to vote for Hillary Clinton
at least partially because you thought
there would be no difference between
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton yet
again we are seeing what would be
significant differences between Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton the leaked
documents where we learned about Trump
cutting this funding also show that
Trump wants to cut other state deport
the Department programs including the
bureau for food security which is
probably going to lose its entire budget
the Bureau of oceans and international
environmental and scientific affairs
losing ninety five percent of this
budget of their budget that sounds
dangerously like an organization that
might know a little bit of about climate
science we certainly don't want to give
them any money so very scary stuff that
we're seeing this is this is money that
actually does things that Donald Trump
is just slashing